vous allez mentir la wave ou à démentir
je sais pas faire moi c'est d'avoir bien
ça valait nul
n'en sait plus à quoi tendent et non pas
par la santé le reste mais c'est comme
fred astaire et ginger rogers quoi c'est
quand vous êtes obligés de vous
retrouver ces mêmes et on fait ça pour
l'argent
ça vous plaît sur la promo
ça n'est même pas du tout veut rien dire
ce mensonge moi ça me fait tout seul
c'est ça m'embête un peu parfois ça
dépend ouais il est bien ce dvd
l'intégrer le 2
c'est une merde commenter la question m
monté mais c'est une
[Rires]
fois il faut l'acheter pour noël ce qui
n'arrange pas non non non tas d'autres
trucs à acheter un achète le dvd baffie
là là à dire des conneries comme ça on
risque de vraiment unique qui la promo
joue l'immédiat continuer avec les
animaux qui oui mais oui mais il peut
dire aussi tome et après je ne mettra
pas pour bien ça y
voilà jamais je me met à poil moi mais
ça n'aurait pas coupé
j'adore laurent gerra
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux